ta mère sait-elle que tu travailles ici non ce
rapport au bureau administratif
international Duncan s'il te plaît signale-le au
bureau administratif international
après que ce soit sur l'AP car ma voix
ne portera pas aussi loin Micro a subi
des dommages majeurs lors d'une
séance de maquillage intense avec la mère de Lewis elle  a une
langue fourchue et une touche d'herpès
je n'ai pas de maman j'ai deux papas dans
ton visage dépêche-toi je suis désolé s'il te plaît dépêche-
toi c'est pressant pressant urgent
urgent je ne peux pas le prendre Preston tu
ne peux pas  plutôt qu'à moitié président comment
ça va quoi de neuf n'est-ce pas quelque chose
non c'était ce grand gars je ne sais pas il est
plus vieux que moi alors qu'est-ce que tu fais
ici pour nous parler et que là-bas
scellant l'affaire avec ce couguar
bien  peut-être chahuteur si vous ne m'aviez pas
appelé ici Duncan, veuillez
retourner voir votre amie, veuillez lui faire savoir
que cette conversation était entièrement
à son sujet dans d'autres nouvelles, c'est très
gênant pour vous